a state farewell
for one of the most important figures in
iran's defense ministry
most of the who was 63 years old
was remembered at a small ceremony in
the grounds of the ministry on monday
fakhrizada's funeral was attended by
some of iran's highest ranking officials
including the head of the country's
atomic energy organization
the head of the revolutionary guards and
this man
the intelligence minister who now has
the job of finding out
how fakhruzada was killed the scientist
convoy of vehicles came under attack in
abasad just east of tehran on friday he
was taken to hospital where he died
fakuzadeh had been on a u.n security
council list of sanctioned individuals
iran had never allowed him to be
interviewed by the international atomic
agency
his whereabouts were always kept secret
and
he has survived a previous assassination
attempt
president hassan rouhani was not at the
funeral but he has blamed israel for the
assassination
a charge israel denies iran's defense
minister says
justice will be done
we will pursue the criminals to the end
and the perpetrators of this crime
will be punished the foreign governments
and international organizations who
refuse to condemn this act of terrorism
will see the consequences of their
crimes
the father of three was gunned down in
front of his wife
and the attackers have not yet been
caught
the assassination is seen as an alarming
security breach inside iran
and there is debate within the country
as to what the response should be
iran's allies are urging restraint
it's not the first time iranian nuclear
scientists have been targeted
but it is the first in the past eight
years and factors of it wasn't just a
nuclear
scientist he was also the head of
research and innovation
at the defense ministry which means he
played a crucial role
in iran's ballistic missile program many
here believe that the death of
fakhrizadeh could play a crucial role in
how
iran might deal with the incoming biden
administration in the united states
in the coming weeks while the
conservative voices in the country are
demanding a tough response
it is ultimately up to the country's
supreme leader ayatollah ali khamenei
to decide on how to proceed and this is
the second time this year
that the country has been mourning the
death of a higher ranking official
the death of major general asian
soleimani in january and now
make it very clear that the road ahead
continues to be a tumultuous one for
iranians
dorsojavari al jazeera